好 早安 各位
我們今天來繼續錄很久沒有上傳的復盤系列
那過幾天我也再來補錄之前
這個CPI公佈跟FED公佈那兩天的復盤好了
那我們今天先來復盤昨天晚上的夜盤
然後在9點半之前這根是會獲利的
不過因為我建議大家9點半之後再開始看盤嘛
所以這個時候大家還在吃飯什麼的
那我們一樣就從9點半開始復盤
然後開盤前是大跌了啦
但是這個美股一開盤就漲了回來
然後這邊是一個黑K嘛
他被漲過了
所以這是一個這個+856的多單
然後
OK
然後這個地方是被跌破了嘛
所以這是一個-853的空單
然後這個停損點的話要設在875才比較好
因為這個873跟875是非常接近的
然後
然後這個黑K被漲過了嘛
所以是844的多單
所以這邊是先加856
然後這個跌破是兩倍的-853
那兩倍意思就是你這邊本來如果是一口小台的多單
這邊你要打兩口小台
讓他反向變成一口空單
然後這邊會再打兩倍的這個
就是例如說兩口小台
讓你的-1變成正1
然後這邊就停損了嘛
那停損點是824
所以這是+844損824
就停損20點
然後這邊是+830
然後Risk是29-3
所以是26+2
Risk是28
所以停力是28*2
就是56
那就830+56
好
所以是886
然後這個中間都
就是這個沒有被跌破嘛
所以算是蠻順利的
都沒有反向
然後這邊就到886了
所以這是一單
56點的停力
OK
然後這根被跌破了嘛
所以這是一個-879
然後停損是897
好
然後被掌過了
所以這邊就停損了
然後這一根被跌破嘛
所以這是一個-909
然後停損會是在918
好
然後又被掌過了
所以這邊停損了9點
好
然後這一根
是14K嘛
雖然它
只有長上隱線沒有下隱線
但我們還是會把開根D一樣的叫做14K棒
然後如果14K棒是在最高點
而且這個是長上隱線的話
那就是
會把它視為是紅K
就是如果它跌破的話就是空單進場
那
因為它是在最高點嘛
所以停損就是設在創新高的地方
那停損設創新高的單是
這個策略裡面是不會開保本的
這是一個細節的差異
那當然一樣如果是在最低點的14K
也是一樣長過打多單
然後這個停損設創新低的地方
然後不會爆本
然後這個Risk是15+2
所以是34
17嘛
17乘2是34
所以停利點是在911-34
877的地方
好
然後這邊就
就沒有再有新的爆打量
所以就成功的停利在877
這個
加34點
然後
然後可以看到後面就
沒有再有新的
這個大量了
所以
後面也就不太需要看了
好
所以這就是
今天的全部
全部的進出位置
然後
這幾單
全部加起來的話
這個
扣掉
7次的
交易的手續費
是加42點
然後當然還要再扣掉一點滑價
那滑價這件事情呢
最主要是跟你的設備有關係
就是
出價單的送出速度跟你的
這個網路的穩定度啊
跟你的設備比較有關
所以我一直跟大家說
就是
絕對不要用手機當充
因為你的滑價會
會比較
比較
那個嘛
會比較大
因為網路一定是
會比有線網路更差的
好
就這樣
然後
這個
過幾天
我應該會再
這個
錄一下
升息
那天
一個晚上賺60萬的
復盤
然後
這個
CPI公佈
應該也可以
錄一下
復盤
好
反正呢
這個
今年的
三萬訂閱目標是
還有一段距離
所以
希望大家可以幫我按個訂閱
然後我最近應該會
到年底前多錄一些YouTube
就這樣啦
大家掰掰